[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
did you guys hear me am i being heard
make sure they can hear
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
what's going on you guys this is at if
we back at the attic show man let me
make sure i f11 this there we go gotta
have it look professional man we gotta
have it look professional
definitely uh you know there's actually
some stuff to talk about today you know
what
this morning cog i was thinking maybe i
shouldn't do it because i don't i don't
normally like going on here if there's
like literally nothing to talk about
but i woke up to like 30 notifications
like well something happened it went
down
it looks like playstation out there uh
they they dropping a little bit of money
and we ain't gonna say it's like
microsoft money but they dropping some
pennies and dimes in the right corners
and uh
you know you know i definitely i think
that's one of the things that people
want to hear about more so we're gonna
go ahead and get on with the show you
know uh
welcome to the attic show where we speak
about the past future and president of
gaming
i got cognito with me what's funny is
cognito mentioned a couple
like a couple days ago he's like what do
you have in the attic show because i
ain't been on it before
and he was asleep this morning when i
went to do the promo and i was like well
i guess
i should promo him and then i was
thinking well he's kind of asleep i
don't know if he can
so i put in the tweet in like
parentheses he's asleep i don't know
yeah that i'm glad you did that because
i was asleep
and i looked at the three i was like oh
yeah i got a short day let me get let me
get moving out here you know what i'm
saying but y'all
had to do it you know saying the ninja
and the wolf combined on your show
you know what i'm saying only right that
i had to be on here so we could talk or
talk
you know what i'm saying what's going on
yo it's like 100 degrees in on new york
city so you have to excuse
my informalness because right now the 8
by 8 struggling it's crazy out here
just wanted to put y'all on to what's
going on out here
it's really struggling man yeah it's
it's hot east coast is hot y'all so
that's that's what this is
a little informal ninja move so first
thing you know
we're going to talk about obviously
playstation buying
uh one studio potentially two then we'll
talk about like
because i see a lot of speculation on
what exactly people want microsoft to do
in the future
in terms of studio acquisitions in terms
of what type of games they want to make
what type of game studios want to make
and just general the direction of the
company itself
and then we'll talk a little bit about
xcloud and how they've leveled up the
infrastructure of
the um you know the the the blades and
stuff because i feel like that's a lot
more
important than a lot of people are late
leading around to be but uh you know uh
so
i feel like we should let's let's just
start with the playstation man because i
feel like that's
that's one of the biggest things and it
really seems like
cognito i didn't know this called needle
but it's okay to talk about accusations
again like
like a couple weeks ago you know an xbox
two would be like yo
they brian carl i think let's talk about
games but now it looks like
you know it looks like it's co it's come
up the pendulums come down on the other
side
and you know uh so what would it when
you woke up because obviously you was
asleep when this happened
what's the first thing you thought of
when you see that they bought
i ain't even trying to pronounce their
name the people who made house mark
the people that made return what was the
first thing you thought about that
um it makes sense it makes sense i mean
the relationship is there
you know these are one of those
situations obviously return did well for
them
you know this is one of those situations
man we we're in the acquisition phase
and i i've already said this from um
from xbox standpoint you know and
playstation i figured would do the same
and these were like
houseblock was always a name that made
perfect sense the relationship was there
you know obviously we've seen what
return is doing out there and they seem
to have that investment with them so
you know look this is what we call this
um it's comfort season so you got you
got to wipe these
these studios out man like because
here's the thing at the end of the day
it's like
you know if you don't you know
people are lurking people are lurking
and and one of those
you know things as far as like you know
besides microsoft
and amazon and you know obviously
google's kind of cooled off a little bit
but um it would make sense for
playstation to make these type of
commitments
you know internally so i think it's a
great move and i'm looking forward to
see
you know what they got going on wait
what do you think though obviously you
know
i made a video about it today i was like
look like
this isn't going to move the needle
because for the most part it's like
playground games on dead labs
these games are already being made
playstation exclusive so it's not like
like for instance if they would have
bought something like you know maybe a
square enix obviously i'm just
shooting a random name out there that
would have been a little more impactful
because you're you're making games
exclusive
uh but for the most part they are doing
these because
microsoft's out there shopping around it
is much kind of relationship that
house mark and sony have microsoft
dropped the right bag that's going out
the window
so they're like you know we we we got to
marry these
the studio man we we can't we can't be
we can't be
letting things just be out in the wind
and then you know we come out to fund
another game we're like oh we've been
bought
i'm sorry so you got to go somewhere
else you know and there's there's
actually a lot of speculation and rumor
out there that that's the reason that uh
you know insomniac was bought is because
they they want to make sure that they
own these studios
and i think you know for the most part
maybe do you think
because they actually own the studio now
that they might you know maybe double
down
in terms of you know what type of
quality in the budget that they have or
do you think that they might just keep
it
going the same way i mean generally what
we we tend to hear when these deals
are talked about and then like these
things are kind of worked on
for a while you know from a legality
standpoint shout out to hogan shout out
to 500 episodes
salute to him but um like usually when
we speak the whole these deals tend to
happen
way in advance it's just that we hear
about them in the public late so
i i assume they've got projects cooking
up you know they've got some things
going on but to your question
yeah i think the investment is going to
be there you're going to see
you know you're going to see sony really
i mean look at this like
returnable got got a nice little shine
to it you know
as far as i'm sure there's a lot of
issues i have with the game but as far
as like
the way that the game is made i like it
it's a solid game
i do feel like there's a lot of little
improvements that they could have made
to do different things but i don't i've
never thought that it was
you know no room for improvement i think
it's a solid foundation yeah
kind of feel like how i feel like about
rice and rome i feel like rise
is a real solid foundation probably an
average to a little bit above average
game
and i feel like if microsoft is able to
get their hands on that ip
and you know i don't know who would make
it but i feel like that
title could be you know i don't like
braiding up like verses but
it could be their god of war maybe not
like the mythological stuff but
what they did and rise they did it well
it's just i felt like they needed to
expand on it
and what's cool like like we talked
about rise on the road we talk about
these kind of things and it's like
we're like damn you know wouldn't be
cool with rise 2 comes out right and it
you know now you look at something like
fraternal right
he had some little issues here and there
technically okay fine but people
dug the concept people loved that idea
you know what i'm saying of
of the biomes and starting over stuff
like that it wasn't for me
personally but i seen you rocking out
i've seen a lot of the community
shout out to kiss boom kiss moves right
you know that's it you brought
yeah like so it goes to show you now the
foundation is there
so boom fraternal too now could be a
potential thing you know i'm saying they
could build they could do things with it
so
i like that kind of stuff and to see
them with sony's back in part of the
family
you know what i mean but you got listen
you got it you got cuffing man it's it's
the season
yes yeah so definitely with the return
thing you know that
i do think that that's a big thing but
there
uh i think it was tokyo japan or or one
of those studios man they
they messed up and instead of tweeting
the house mark image they tweeted the
blue point image so
it's it's highly highly likely
that sony owns both of those studios now
and to me i feel like this one's a
little bit
better than the other one because uh you
know as good as house mark is i feel
like blue point just makes better
quality games
and i think that sony has such a vast
library stuff that they don't mess with
and a vast library of stuff that you
know stuff like naughty dogs made in the
past
and stuff like you know uh up until
ratchet and clint came back like
i feel like a lot of people want blue
point to make newer ips
but i think they're fine what they're
doing now they bring older franchises
bring it back
and then who knows maybe if one of these
older franchises they bring back
gets a lot of momentum they just let
them continue that franchises
their game yeah yeah i mean the
first of all shout out who is it it was
playstation
shout out to playstation fan just just
give it up all the information just just
just out here try snitching all the
stupid
i think it's funny i think it's funny
like normally zodie is airtight for the
most part
so to see this happen to me recently
here recently it's not really been like
that like when we did that
they did that event last year if you
remember correctly like
they had all multiple trailers that was
coming to pc coming to other platforms
right right you're right yeah
like yeah we messed up that's that
that's not supposed to happen
they had um their gran turismo being the
playstation 5 exclusive
in a trailer like like the communication
there doesn't seem to be very good here
recently i don't know what's going on
there so like
did you like you know do you which one
of these do you think is
is the bigger juggernaut to actually own
and not necessarily just be partnered
with
it's interest i'ma surprise you
i know where you going but i think the
only reason why i say house spark
is because correct me if i'm wrong
doesn't blue point
make a lot of the remasters like they
made the demon souls remastered
they made the uncharted so correct me i
just want to know from um
like original ips i don't think they've
ever made an
original idea right now i'm not
questioning them saying that they can't
get busy
but i think obviously house mark has a
little bit more experience
you gotta be kidding me
i don't think they've ever made it
can you guys still hear me
hello
oh okay okay it's it's not me man it's
not me it's cognito
i thought something was wrong man hold
up hold up let me
let me make sure you guys can hear me
can you guys hear me
can you guys hear me okay okay
cog he he had his power uh flip off so
you know he'll i'm sure he'll come back
you know what let's let's talk a little
bit about you know
the the potential that they have with
these while i wait for cog to come back
here
i personally feel like this is a good
move now you guys know
i've always been on that thing where i'm
just like look like
they need this studio they need these
studios in general because
we can't lie what microsoft is doing
over there
is a huge movement you can't have
scenarios
where microsoft has so many studios and
so many teams making a game
that sure they might not have the best
games
they might not have the the best games
like the naughty dog games the saint
monica games
but all it takes is a lot of really good
games
to make it a lot easier on microsoft and
i think
i think they knew that i think they know
that this is one of those scenarios
where they're going to have to put their
money where their mouth is
and they're going to have to try to make
that a little bit more even now
they can easily make a you know studios
be bigger have them
make multiple games but i've always felt
like
it's better to have individual studios
make different things than have multiple
teams make different games because
the problem with multiple teams having
different games if that a
team is having issues they're going to
pull that b team off to help help that a
team
and that that's just my opinion on the
matter but you know
i want you guys in the chat tell me what
get what studio
blue point or how smart which one's
better
tell me what which one you think would
be the best system
in the best game that they could
possibly make because me personally
i feel like it's blue point because i i
i just think there's so many good games
that they can make
and even if they don't like strictly
stay with playstation games
i feel like there's so much different
possibilities that they have
as as making older games you know
it let's say that they didn't want to
make um
let's say they wanted to to continue and
go and make something from a different
company
they got that option they tried to hate
on me the heat trying to stop me
i'm saying they try to hate on the kid
he silenced me so he silenced me man
i apologize yeah he's definitely yeah i
thought my internet went out no no it
was me this time
my whole joint shut off like because i
got the ac on full tilt
in an apartment and um i just seen
everything go boom
so i had to shut it down so yeah we're
operating off for oscillating fan and
less power that's
good back back yeah so you know what
what i wanted to bring this back to a
little before we go on the next topic
is you know what we've saved for a long
time it's like look
sony i i love how the people
always say sony doesn't need to compete
in terms of studios
now i've always been on the standpoint
that they could definitely compete with
the multiple teams on multiple projects
but i feel like
if the longer time goes by the more
microsoft's going to get
games in the bag at one point is it
going to be an issue
here recently what i'm sorry what
what's going to be issue i missed that
of the differences in between studios
like you can have the multiple teams
but people are acting like microsoft's
not doing that too
like ninja theory don't got one game
studio oh yeah
like sony can definitely do the multiple
teams to compete with the quality of
games with the multiple teams
but i feel like in order to really
compete in the next couple years when
microsoft gets this machine going
they're gonna have to have more studios
as well they can't just rely
on the studios that they currently have
so and then people said well
i love how people are attacking me on
twitter and they're saying addict
this isn't this has nothing to do with
with um
microsoft they just they naturally buy
these studios
so i went and i looked like you know how
often they buy a studio it's not often
they buy a studio like maybe every three
or four years
they bought two studios in three years
wow
and it's looking like they bought three
because blue point is definitely being
bought
a shout out to dillard gaming he's he's
hinting they bought the people that made
guilty gear
so you know and i and i trust dillard
dale is usually pretty solid on that he
was sent that down on twitter
like this is definitely them
saying yo we can't let microsoft buy
everything we got to buy some of these
ourselves
yeah i mean we we can't ignore the fact
even though obviously this is a
playstation topic right
we can't ignore the fact that microsoft
is out here in acquisition phase but
we hear their name associated with
everything wb
i mean even before let's be real right
it was so crazy that before
e3 we were like surprised and
disappointed
that they have nothing to announce at e3
when we heard things with cooking right
so at the end of the day it's like you
know sony would be smart to lock these
things in again if you already have
these relationships you've already made
these games
you know they work together it makes
perfect sense the other thing i was
saying before i got cut off was that um
you know with with house walk obviously
they have that establishment already
they have a couple of ips they have a
little bit more season
you know i believe they did a resume too
if i'm not mistaken but um
so now it's cool to see what bluepoint
could do
because prior their history has been
predominantly
remastered i'm assuming in like a
support kind of role
so that actually is excited to see what
they could do with their own vision
i don't think they're going to i think
they're going to be stuck in a rematch
it's not that they're going to be just
going to be in a remaster mode i think
they there's not too many people that
can bring back an old ip as well as they
do and that's a rare gift and i don't
think sony's just gonna let them run
wild on new stuff
like because like what they did with
demon souls what they
what they did with the um what's that
other game they made a couple years ago
the one with the giant costume shout out
to classes
not every studio can do stuff like that
like it takes special studios a special
talent
and a special vision to to bring older
games
back into the new into the new world in
a decent way
and i feel like it would be different if
they if they went out and
you know they had a new ip and then
sony's like yeah let's buy them off that
but they really have only done this so
to me
i mean sony couldn't possibly give them
that opportunity
but i'm just looking at it from a
perspective of what they've done for
sony up till now
to me they're buying they're buying them
to lock
that talent down because they don't want
other people to feel that
but at it if you gonna put a ring on it
you gotta let them do something around
the house i mean they're just stuck
around the house like
see you like keep cooking and cleaning
here's the thing though
sony don't need just they go they got
multiple wives they
that this is the one that that comes off
on like the saturdays between the
the the naughty dog and insomnia like
this
isn't like this isn't a studio that
they're going to put like an
invest like a ton a ton a ton of money
behind like i
feel you on the price you ain't throwing
the bad but if you
gonna put a rig on it they got to do
something they got to contribute
what they got to do they basically
contributing they're just gonna be the
remaster studio that's it i mean that
that's all they've really ever done
games like i feel like at this point
if they were gonna do something fresh
they'd have done it by now they've made
like
games for them all right so let's go
ahead so so why if that's the case
why don't they just keep them as is and
let other support studios because they
don't want someone like microsoft buying
them and having microsoft do the same
[ __ ] they want to do
because at the end of the day like sony
has a huge variety of stuff that they
can have them work on
but so does microsoft so does nintendo
like right this is this isn't a studio
that's like that that that is an average
piece i wanted to say something crazy i
know what you like
jonathan b said you trying to make this
this is a studio
that has a particular set of skills like
i'm done
at the end of the day like like sure
they might do that
for like in the future but i would say
their next game
most definitely they've been rumored to
do the metal gear solid game like
like that is a talent like remaking
older games is a huge talent and
i don't think so because first off
making games from scratch costs way more
money than making
god they got the bag but look
they don't even want dave gone to make
the bag like they're like
you're gonna do what we want you to do i
know you want you you want to make days
going to
you making a new ip and it costs more
money to make a new ip so they're
clearly not going to get the type of
budget that they had what they've gone
so like to me you have a winning formula
that they've done
and they've done well to me sony's not
taking the risk
to double the funding for that studio
when they're making plenty of money
doing what they're doing now and they're
being extremely successful
there's one argument that you have that
i cannot dispute
when obviously the jason schreyer thing
came out and we heard about
days going right where you have a point
is sony's focus
well alleged focus it's just a legend
but it was it did come out shout out to
trying to
you know as far as the um blockbuster
focus
right so when we heard about that
remember we did iop we was upset we was
like yo
like why they're not allowing days going
two days ago and deserve the secret
regardless of how you felt about it
it did well enough financially and you
know it scored
pretty decently to deserve a sequel so
that's the question
the question becomes do they do the
status quo
of the quote-unquote jim ryan era so to
speak
of focusing on the blockbusters and
doing that
kind of thing or do you do the microsoft
approach which is kind of like
you know have a variety diverse lineup
and allow them to be creative but
to your point it what it
so far it seems like mike i mean
microsoft sony has definitely
kept them in that bag and they're the
you know remastered support and stuff
like that
me personally i would like them to do
new
at least a shot at one yeah what their
own vision could be
i think sony right now especially
they're just going to go
they're going to take as less risk as
possible uh that that's why they
they're they're having you know ben's
studio make a new ip
most likely not on the same type of
budget that uh that day's gone was
that's why they're making the last of us
remaster or remake
like they're they're taking the the the
safety way
they're taking the safety net man they
what is
i think in the baseball term they're
taking the hit from the ball so they can
go straight to first base like
yeah you got that you got to do you know
what i'm saying i mean look
we can't deny to your point even though
i still disagree but to your point
you know we can't deny the success of
their established ips right
they're established blockbusters you
know that's why i feel like
they really will just keep the studio
doing what they're doing because they
don't need those type of games they got
those games like
like the the the skill and i want to
highlight again the skill that they have
of being able to remake
older games in such a high quality way
yeah it's a tower
it's not something that you can get
anywhere and they have such
a mass bag of games that they can
pull out of that it's like oh you know
uh
they can be extremely diverse they can
be extremely agile in the market
when they're not locked down on one
typical type of game they're like okay
you finished
demon souls we got that out look we
we're missing this
this type of game but we have this from
20 years ago that we ain't made
go make this and then it's it's like i
was saying when you lagged out like
let's say that sony decides we don't
want
them to make our games anymore they can
license out games from capcom
like like supposedly uh
castlevania game they can license out of
castlevania go remake symphony of the
dark whatever the hell that game is
called like
so i feel like they're more effective to
them
as doing something that they are really
good at right
than it is for them to probably most
likely double the budget that it would
take to make these games
to make something new something fresh
because they're gonna have to
have they're gonna have to have multiple
people working on stories multiple
people working on
a world and to me what i've seen sony do
like i agree with you i want them to
make a new game
but at the end of the day i don't think
of what they've shown me what sony has
shown me
that they're they're more they want to
give that kind of funding to the to the
people going to make them that money to
like the
the the naughty dogs the saint monica's
like they want
them people to have the the balls to the
wall budget
and they and they want to play it safe
to get this easy return back
to to your point again even though i
disagree but you making some valid
points in the sense of
you got to look at the rumors right i'm
i'm team ninja and we're hearing about
this goes to sashima
um you know potential directors cut
right which is another
what is i guess we're going to consider
it a remaster they're saying a
playstation 4 version the playstation 5
version
whatever whatever so to your the
defending your argument if the focus
seems to be in this direction of focus
on the blockbuster remaster
then maybe yeah maybe that's what it is
i don't want it but
maybe that's what it is because i think
that like if you got a houseboat oh they
go
there what's up let's go this is super
chat man
let's go five dollar super chat for
involving us definitely butcher your
name we're gonna move right past that
so who will be the first media outlet
that will ask
uh house uh house hello
house mark are they going to keep their
games exposed
shout out to my bad daddy play did you
see his tweet yeah
what's funny is like remember when we
said last week i was like um
when we it was some kind of studio i was
oh yeah when we were talking about the
the overwatch 2 not the overwatch 2 the
sunset overdrive too and i was saying
that
if they were able to work away and get
like the spider-man 2
like just snatch the license from sony
and then microsoft's making a spider-man
2
and sony's making sunset overdrive too
only one of those studios is going to
get asked are they exclusive the other
one's not
like yo it keeps save energy right
because if yo maddie had the perfect
change he's like i don't know guys
you know after this file spark you know
we gotta see if these games gonna come
over the xbox
i was like yo maddie being messing son
it was a it was
s t tweet tweet as far as sarcasm
i'm not to talk to big cloud man next
time he has a houseboat
i'm actually like dude you gotta ask
them man is this game
exclusive to places yeah we gotta we
gotta we gotta find out cause you know
if you spend this amount of money
there's a chat they gotta recruit they
gotta recruit man remember that
remember these guys gotta be everywhere
man
people are funny it's like they can't
they can't risk i mean
what's funny is they say playstation
xbox can't risk the millions the
hundreds of million plus people
on playstation but playstation
easily doesn't go to pc and that's
hundreds of millions of
customers too so it's just like look at
the end of the day
sure are they missing a lot of money yes
but it's like i've said
over and over again putting games on
xbox and pc does devalue the xbox
brand but it's only to cons to to
to pc gamers it's not to console gamers
because they're going to only play on
calls so to pc gamers
they're just like look you don't want
our console anyway you just want our
game
and chances are you're only going to
play one or two of our games anyway so
if we give it to you on your platform
you have a better chance of picking up
the game anyway yeah shout out to always
caller being messy he's
like he said when are we gonna get an
apology from hospital
yo this video they silly but it's funny
it's funny to see
you know how narrative shifts you know
when it's your favorite that buys
you know your favorite company that buys
a studio and stuff like that
again we save energy but look it's a
good move
you know i am very curious to see what
happens on our thoughts with with if
what they make next
you know if they just you know continue
to do the remaster thing that'll be
oh look we got to get the flame that's
loads of gaming.net you got to fight out
scripts from flame
ironically the acquisition does not feel
less impactful house mark has always
made us
oh it does fall house mark has always
made gains for playstation i gotta
wonder what actually changes
that's what i said it's like the undead
labs
the playground games they always made
games for xbox so it didn't really
it wasn't impactful it's mainly for
making sure
that these studios are going to be
making games for them in five years
that's what
these these decisions have been made
yeah then we got to fight dollar stream
chat from the wise old gamer question
how much was the purchase because of
talent how much was motivated from the
fear of microsoft
i said it on twitter and i got destroyed
wise old gamer
i said they 100 went and bought these
studios because
look at the end of the day it's like i
said microsoft uh sony
and these studios house market and blue
point probably have a fantastic
huge type of relationship yes but when
you hand
20 30 above market value to these
companies
they're going to be like sony you're not
paying me this kind of money like
so you're gonna have to you'll have to
match it or i'm gonna have to sell to
microsoft like
actually look at the end of the day it's
business right it's big business so
it don't matter how good the
relationship with someone drop the bag
back the truck up and say we want you
you know what i'm saying got to got to
have you i got to have you
yes it's cuffing season you you gotta
you know what i'm saying so it's like
you can't play no games right now this
is a very this is an
acquisition phase game passes out here
you know
all these subscription models and things
like that you need content you need
games on the service and if you don't
have it
yeah you know big fellas out here you
know what i'm saying you know i'm saying
like
10 cent is out here you know amazon's
still out here
you can't play these games so lock it
down
we all knew that this was a name that
was always synonymous like flame says so
like like you said it's going to be
interesting to see what actually changed
by the scene
but this and blue point yeah this super
chat's interesting
uh that's kai dollar superchat from iron
mike the only big purchase of these
rumors three would be
arc uh arcsense creators of dragon ball
fighterz
and the other two already make ps
exclusive games anyway
you know what's interesting about that
art game or the ark studio
i didn't know they made fighter z
because i don't keep up with fighters
like that they don't exist to me like
that
but um it's interesting because sony
owns fundamentation and they're about to
own
crotchy rocks and guess guess what ark
loves making
anime fighters and they own
fundamentation and soon to be
crunchyroll does that mean that
you know they're 100 be able to get the
licensing for these games no
but it's like evo when you have
something such as evo and something such
as fundamation
and crunchyroll these people who own
these ips aren't trying to piss you off
like so i think they'll be easily bl if
they take that
i would say that first off the next
dragon ball z fighters 2 is going to be
an exclusive playstation which is a big
move
because it's it's like i was saying with
the mortal kombat thing i was like if
microsoft's not buying nether realm sony
needs to make that acquisition
themselves and people was like oh they
already have the fighter market
it it never hurts to double dip in a
market that you want to own
mm-hmm absolutely especially with um
sony
with the commitment to the what is it
the evo fighting championships you know
what i'm saying
listen sony has been in that bag as far
as keeping fighting alive you can't take
that away from so
you know being that we is on another
realm thing you know i don't know if
we're transitioning yet but
you know that's something i want
microsoft to see if it's possible
to seriously consider because you got
killer stick out here that neither
developer can phil already put that out
there
that they're still looking for that and
i think that's microsoft's achilles
heels besides just one actually just one
they need fighters they don't have a lot
of fighters man that that's that
to be honest with you like we'll go
ahead and transition like yeah all right
so
my next topic it's like i said there's a
lot of stuff going on with the xbox
there's a lot of speculation going on
i want to know like top three things
that you want from microsoft in the
future
it could be studio acquisitions it could
be games
it could be anything in relating to that
matter what if you was over there
and and phil sat you down he's like carl
what can we do like like i want
i want the cog way let's of of
what we can do to get this back to where
it was going
i mean they doing it right now like they
they doing the uh subscription i mean
subscription
the studio acquisition stuff right
because you gotta
create the content um you know
first there's always going to be just
one and for those who don't know who are
in here
or 240 i hit the like button my man
attic out here young wolf doing this
thing with this show
so um what i was going to say is like
you really
you the reason why i'm so adamant right
is because sony
fan base and sony's success
a lot of it we can't deny i was
predicated on the fact that those
third-person
cinematic over-the-shoulder type games
did well for them i'm not telling
microsoft
to do their whole lineup like that they
have a diverse lab
just make one they need something for
the new generation what i'm saying so
that's that
um it's just games bro it literally the
games got to be quality man
quality games giving them time to cook
um i want them to continue
this diversity as far as um game pass
and as far as the lineup the japanese
games things that we were talking about
and reference to that i want i want game
pass to have his tendrils everywhere i
know we kind of seen it right now with
you know the tvs and we're seeing it
with mobile and we've seen it with all
these different things but
i don't you know what you know what they
got to do they gotta do a better job
of marketing game pass to the casual
i mean i know twitter right now is kind
of liquid so that's funny but
you know what i'm saying like you know
joe blow down the streets sometimes
don't know what game pass is
you see what i'm saying like a lot of
people still don't
know you know what i'm saying shout out
oh shout out to the wazzo gamer um nah
hellblade 2 does not count as just one
because technically it's a sequel
even though i know it fits the genre but
that's why i was all gaming but um yeah
i think that that's the first two things
um i just i like the diversity
i like the commitment to power i like i
like
what game pass is a deal and i like that
microsoft is involved they're literally
doing it to be honest it's like
it's just quality games it's just now
the game's got to hit you your point is
like
they do they've set the track the trains
on it
it's just you got to make sure the track
is finished
the train can't derail in the middle of
the transportation
facts you got to close the deal because
you could do all this studio buying
and if these games ain't you know it's
overall whatever you do i don't care
about metacritic like that but if the
better you know what's how you know i go
with the metacritics the 1760s
you know the fanboys or whatever feeling
they get their feelings but
the games got it they need those
critically acclaimed
like when you go to the games award and
you're like yo
two microsoft titles was up for game of
the year
like we they need that but yeah that's
why they bought that kojima thing
oh for sure hey kojima we get kiwi off
the
top you feeling my master flag still
about
to play it's like it's like we need
these games getting game over the years
like someone call kojima
yeah man now they do they need to
because again let's be real the games
narrative is almost dead the gang guy
don't get that's that's almost
right so now it just comes down to the
new thing is going to be yo
how many critically acclaimed games you
have how many games that move the needle
how many games that people say
yo that was one of the games of the
generation they
need that and i know halo's gonna do
what halo do i know forza is gonna do
what forza do
gear's gonna do what gears do but we
need the new ips for the new
generation that we go yo these are fire
you know what i'm saying and i think
they got diversity down and they still
the best
deal in gaming so they're going to be
around they're going to be around for
sure
i think about you what you think what
they what they need what needs to be
done
i think the diversity needs to get a
little bit better i think they need to
reach out
if they're able to buy another realm to
make a killer instinct
regardless if they feel like the fighter
markets lost it because i do i think
it's lost to them but i think they
they need it at this point they need
their own exclusive that's the only
thing they can do to even remotely fix
that
and i don't think it'll ever be fixed
because what people don't realize the
relevancy
of sony buying evo sony owns the
head-to-head market huge
huge and to to me it's like so you know
you're not going to be able
to really hit that market huge but what
you can do
is you have to make the best game in
that market yeah and it's like you you
make sure the money's right the talent's
right and killer instinct and if they're
able to get uh mortal kombat you'll own
mortal kombat and killer instincts
you you supply that studio enough to
make two teams and they're dropping out
mortal kombat and killer incident every
two years and then
uh and then the the years between the
two years is a mortal kombat versus
killer instinct
and i feel like you know you can't beat
them you might as well make the majority
of the games that comes into that genre
you it's like look you want to always be
in the talk you're not going to be the
best you're not going to be the street
fighters
you're not going to be the you know the
the guilty gears i don't know how
i don't know the fighter mark i'm
throwing out names but at the
the tekkens but you you want to always
be regardless if you can't be in that
room because you don't really have a say
you want to have a player in that room
that's always being talked about
it's like yo killer instinct was lit
like you always want to have this
conversation so we got a five dollar
strip of shrimp from chivo
walker i butchered your name again man i
apologize for that
i definitely butchered that one so much
we are going to we're not moving past
that i gotta apologize for that one
again
uh what uh what do you think about the
announcement that xbox is the
uh official home of battlefield 2042
it's a good move it just depends on what
type of
original uh home are they talking about
official home is it is it are they gonna
name that game past day and date in a
couple months like
because to me if you're going to make
sure you're the you're the official home
you need something that makes your home
look more better than the other home
so it's like if they literally just get
the marketing rights that's not really a
home
like like that that's like a billboard
outside that goes through all the
neighborhoods like you see those from
the casuals the casuals
sometimes you know they get a lot of
people think it's like they need like
exclusive dlc or or first on things wait
are you engaging
in practices that's going to lock things
away that's what we're doing
look like i'm just being real like i'm
saying that when it comes to
this place being the home i feel like
being home means there's something
unique at that home that makes it the
home oh
you want an exclusive that's not going
to happen because phil don't
he don't believe in exclusive dlcs but
to me if it's going to be the home
it needs to have a reason why you would
consider that home like
back in the day call of duty you got 30
days of the dlc first on xbox
that's why people consider that the home
of of call of duty because how long are
we locking the battlefield maps how long
are we locking them man
for what sony's done with me and they're
trying to i don't want to give them i
don't want to ever have them have it
like
but you know that's not my decision it's
like at the end of the day
i'd love for for microsoft to walk in
there
and just catch the it just sit there
like you know like those
those old mobster movies where they just
kept like the elevator on fire
and then it just goes up and blaze and
and then microsoft just looks so he's
like you're not going up there
but you know it is what it is uh i just
i hope battlefield's a good game because
i've always liked battlefield i kind of
fell off the past couple entries
i don't like the old stuff and then i
didn't really like battlefield v
i i don't like battlefield 1 battlefield
5. i like battle before
i'm hoping this game brings battlefield
back to what it used to be
yeah and we'll have to see man we'll
have to see so okay let me
let me continue with mine all right so
we talked about
the diversity like you know we get the
head-to-head fighters
i honestly feel like they need their own
jrpg studio
and i feel like it's like phil spencer
said when he was over there and they
said
you know you uh your your your
your your system's not on our shelves i
feel like
loki they might not tell him openly
but it's like you don't even support our
brand enough to have your own studio in
our country so it's just like japan
and then i guess they technically have
one now because
of the acquisition with but but to me
like they don't really make
jrpgs they make like horror game stuff
like in
like that's a good way to get your to
get a ground in there where you can
you can branch out and you can buy
something else
but at the end of the day they need a
jrrpg because to me
jrpgs is what made the industry what it
is now
back in the day the final fantasies the
chrono triggers the dragon quest like
those games they might not have
necessarily
you know made the other genres but they
made those genres so popular
that people was more comfortable
exploring other genres right
so i'm just i'm sorry i just wanted wise
old
is feeling everything you talk about he
throwing it up he's like thank you
addict thank you from talk about
what about this to your point which i
like what about
cultivate and develop your own
studio in japan to do said task
they could do that but they're going to
have to get a heavy hitter
to lead it because i don't what about
that could be good over there
i don't want kojima touching jrpgs let
him over there be in his zone
he can be in whatever every realm he
decides to be in
i can't see him making that jrpg but
i don't know what this man is like it
whatever it is it's gonna be creepy
like like do i get enough of that from
uh from
from what's that game from kingdom
hearts i don't need
no more blow my mind off but kingdom
hearts have been blowing my mind off for
15 years i don't need no more of it
all right so just that wacky over the
top you don't want that that you don't
want me to go for kojima in your jail
you never go full kojima
so you know and you know nothing takes
away from
the the stuff he's done in the end right
but you just like
i think he's better off than the genre
to be honest with you i think he needs
to go to tv
and movies yeah i think he needs to get
out of the gaming industry because
his mind is more of like i'm i'm gonna
make a tv show
i'm gonna make a movie i think that's
something he would do
he has a lot of those those western
influences obviously
whatever in pop culture he knows
obviously walking dead was popping he
got norman reedus
you know what i'm saying you know daryl
dixon and all that um i'm just i guess
maybe the kajima thing was wrong as far
as him being a choice for jrpg
but what i mean is like they do need a
popular face
that's respected over there to run it
and say okay such-and-such is over there
let's just say for example you know you
you know the final fantasy guys better
your final fantasy game well the
original creators right the original
creator of final fantasy miss walker but
they've been in their own little world
like yeah i get it the best thing
the best thing that they could do
there's a couple of scenarios that they
could
remedy this one is buying sega because
then they wouldn't need to do anything
ever again
like they would own the entire japanese
like not the japanese market but they
would
have a good pulse on it they would they
would own persona
uh valkyrie chronicles that that's
that's a turn-based game they would own
that
they would own the yakuzas and like the
dragons doing really
and i think that one purchase would be
enough to get their foot
in that market sega that's why and it's
it's
it's the perfect marriage they they've
already
that's on my list but how did i forget
of what i want for
i was saying i'm a sega kid of course i
was saying what's wrong with me
so yeah like that it's the perfect
marriage and sake already has that
history
they've already kind of been working
nice together synonymous they got rid of
the pachinko division
if they came out next year at e3 or even
maybe exo this e3
and they show persona 6 on their stage
and at the end of it atlas like it pops
up you know that black weird screen
they'd be doing
it says atlas and then it's just like
pow microsoft studio at the right
and then and then like it zooms up and
all the rest of the sega studios shows
up and it says microsoft studio
you're gonna see grown man tears for me
bro i'm telling you that's my heart
that's my
sega like i'm a sega kid from day one
how'd it happen you know what's gonna
happen though man the first
interview with sega are these exclusive
[Laughter]
because you know we've got to make sure
that you can recoup and then you know
what else though you know another thing
like
i've never seen the value of game pass
that for
for one dollar you can get three months
and you can get all the sega games
bro i'm just thinking about the lineage
of sega titles
that could also be brought back with a
modern twist
then you talk about the jrpg stuff
we're not
imagine xbox like microsoft put some
money behind
don't get me started bro like that's the
dream right there i need that to happen
man that's
that would be okay you went in
generations now for me
i personally feel like right now
probably microsoft is
their division like look we have games
that we 100
studios we trust 100 not necessarily
trust 100
but they have a lot a lot of faith in
the obsidians they have
faith in you know the initiative
coalition
they got these studios are like they're
they're go
tear ones man it's like the favorite
child like like
these are the ones that don't get asked
to sit in the middle ground man they
they're not kicked out of the uh out of
the the
the thanksgiving table man they're not
asked to leave the room
like these are the ones that help mom
make the dinner like
and you know and then the other studios
the undead labs the compulsions they're
great studios
but i feel like microsoft they're
wanting to do what sony done with their
games for years
they want to to really you know go over
all these studios with fine tooth comb
like let them make the games let them
find out good scenarios that they can
make the games
help them nurture these studios up to
where
maybe in five years uh ninja theory's
making
on par rocks not rockstar
uh naughty dog level games because they
nurtured these studios they
they they let them built internally
because you can't like sure
they've kind of nurtured themselves but
when you're always worrying about
your stuff being shut down and you're
always and you're having to split your
stability
you're having to split your studio up in
like eight different things to make
sex six or seven different games it's
hard to really nurture a studio that way
we got a couple of super chats we got a
five dollar super chat from uh
lucious i wish a guest
yeah we need something maybe it's the
spanish in him because
i'm too white to read something man like
when he get that little
sega means yakuza persona and jet set
radio
i want uh i j i really want sega to be a
part of microsoft
sega microsoft would take down sony i'm
not going to go out there and say
they're going to take something
over the world he's going for it all
right i will say
that that's one of those things though
that sony gonna have to like scratch
that
what's funny you know colin said on his
last podcast
he says that he thinks elder scrolls
five uh
six is going to be on uh on playstation
you know why he says that
because he is convinced that game pass
is gonna be on playstation by that guy
oh okay i get i get i get it i get it so
you take it back
so we got a five dollar trooper shot
from rubber knob
imagine coming up with the final boss in
halo infinite it's a sonic teamed up
with crap
he loses he loses that sounds like a
kingdom hearts fight
um so okay so let's go a little bit with
the uh the direction of the diversity
you know you get that diverse you get
that jrpgs you get that
fighter market and that you know you
make sure that you're building one or
two to three studios to make those uh
you know those those third-person action
adventure games that call
wants you know he wants one i don't
necessarily think that they have to be a
new ip
i just think it has to be a good game
like people are going to look over that
i mean it is what it is i know we
disagree with that i
i've always no no you can have both i
just feel like yeah
like in terms of people want good games
and i think
the people that would try to discredit
like let's say hellblade comes out and
it's a phenomenal game oh yeah he's
gonna do what it does
it's gonna do fine i do think people
would resonate more with a newer ip
but i think at the end of the day as
long as it's a good game people are
gonna gravitate
towards that the most i agree you're
right you're right but to me
we were just talking about what we want
right we talk about what would be
dominant you know there is a little
truth i'm not going to get caught up
with fanboy narrative but there is a
little truth
that i shouldn't say truth there's a
little fear
that oh when microsoft acquires you
you're not going to make the same level
quality game as a new ip
right so to me that's why it's important
starfield hits it's important
anything under the xbox game studios
umbrella that's
new hits because you crushed that
narrative
right now they're crushing their game
past now they're crushing the power now
they're crushing they need that one now
because then you can't say it anymore
that oh you know see what happened
underneath the microsoft banner you know
look see they
they putting out this less than quality
stuff and they weren't better off
whatever
that's certain narratives people run
with you know the crazy part i truly
believe
that the people there in compulsion can
make that game of course
i know it i think because they're so
good at story right like people
i know a lot of people you know they
kind of look down on we happy few
and rightfully so there was a lot of
issues with we happy few and
a lot of it wasn't their fault they they
they went from a um
from a what was it like from a
crowdfunding game they had to change it
up because they got a publisher
there were so many issues with that game
but look i'm not telling you guys to go
out there and 100 give we happy few a
chance what i'm telling you
is go give the expansions a chance
because those are they was kind of one
away from the survival aspects that we
have people
and they're story oriented and they're
dark as hell
they're good so we gotta we got two five
dollars super attached real quick
taylor blaze i think if microsoft
acquires take two that's
generations if they acquired take do
imagine what twitter would be like
twitter would be on
fire it would be over i wouldn't have
i would literally take the day off of
work i'd have to call my boss be like yo
i gotta call in because i gotta watch
twitter be on fire
twitter would would implode outpo catch
on fire that implode again
all in a matter of like tim's gonna see
the world burning
yeah just imagine that that happened it
would be phenomenal
you want to see grow bigger they
feelings that's what you listen
yeah so we got five dollars superchat
from lord maxi
microsoft should uh make a new uh mace
fighting game
uh or uh karito chunkin
you have to read that i cannot that
seems like a you kind of phrase
oh he said microsoft should make a new
maze fighting game or
children tile fighting fest of the lotus
okay some some real channel five
kung fu flick you know what i'm saying
vibes okay
yeah i'm all about it i was not reading
none of that man
i wasn't butchering eight things all
right man i see what you guys are doing
i see what you guys are doing
and he wasn't he was like i can't add it
can't
pronounce certain things so let's hit
him with like eight of them
i saw that back to back yeah so you know
that's all i want and it's like look
i i guess the biggest thing i want for
them is like look
make sure we don't have another you know
presenting that we saw last year with
halo
i don't care what kind of game it is
clearly what we saw last year
i do have a i do really think that a lot
of the reason that happened last year
was because of the pandemic i don't
think that because you got to remember
what when e3
that july event happened last year it
was in the middle like
dead ass in the middle of this whole
pandemic facts
and i think there was they didn't have a
whole lot they could do at that time
i'm not giving as an excuse to that
because there should have been someone
at the top that's like
you know we we we should probably delay
the presentation
but you know at the end of the day it's
like i said on podcast last year that
wasn't a scenario that i don't think no
one would have gave them a password yeah
every everybody's affected and we can't
act like they're not right you know what
i'm saying we're seeing
you know even with you know the return
on situation we talked about hospital
you know we had some issues there
you know we had some issues with halo
infinite as far as showing
you know i know people don't like to
hear it but working under a pandemic is
difficult as a development studio
you know they're working on remotely is
not the same as being in the same room
collaboratively because yeah
it's like and i just love how gamers
just poo poo that
i don't care this thing was broken and
you know and it's like bro it's like
you know what's funny yeah it was we're
not gonna give them
that excuse because i
it's like i said yesterday on colt's
podcast definitely go check that out you
guys but
you know being cog was on i was only on
there for like 35 minutes because of my
interviews
that i have we talked about cgi being
shown
at an e3 and i said this year
they get a pass because at the end of
the day like
you could see that the pandemic affected
that whole e3 this year
that's why you saw certain studies like
ubisoft showing very few gameplay
there wasn't a lot of gameplay at all at
e3 because they don't have access to the
studios like they do
so like right now people are finally
going back to studios
and we just got vaccines like what like
two or three months ago like
they're just recently started going back
to the supermarket
slowly and even that is still different
you still got the social distance you
still got a certain amount of things you
could do
it it's slowly getting back we might not
see the ramifications
you know 2022 that's what all studios
that's what i thought was funny because
people was like
oh sony's doing it sony doing it so
remember that yeah
but but then when horizon didn't get a
release date when god of war got pushed
back
and then when they came out openly and
said yo we don't know if horizon's
coming out this year
no there's no one saying about the coven
thing it's like
as long as if sony doesn't get to pass
they feel like no one should get the
pass and if sony does get the pass they
should feel like everyone should get the
pass just people
trying to twist their own narratives
because they they fanboy is showing
and when you let your fanboys show you
know i mean at the end of the day
instead of just being a gamer and
actually
being realistic about the situation as
if your company and your studio is
absolved from
you know we we don't have any problems
over here i don't know what's going on
with mike
you don't say like once you get into
that bag and you don't look at the
realistic situation you always blind in
yourself so
that's why in a way i never wish
anything bad on anyone but it was good
that it happened because people could
see
yes even sony even nintendo yeah
everyone is affected
so they people just got to stop so
here's my big
we're about to move on to the last topic
but i want to ask you right now
what is the one game that has been
announced
that you feel like is going to hold the
most weight at microsoft
like that that means the most that that
game comes out what
future at all like all the games that's
been announced which one you think is
going to do the most
numbers and what what game you think is
going to mean the most that's two
different ones
i think starfield's going to be very
much important i think starfield is
critical
and the reason being is we haven't this
is 18 bethesda
we know the exclusivity right there's a
little bit of pressure there there's
you know i mean let me let's just put it
this way we just talked about impact
if starfield is a game of the year
contender underneath the microsoft
brand that's powerful
now this year i would say halo but i
mean at this point halo's already
even if halo tripped a little bit it's
still
halo people still gonna have love for it
we know what halo is
we don't know what star field is and if
star field is revolutionary
and it and it puts bethesda back because
let's be real the narrative is like you
know for after fallout 76
they lost a little tarnish on they start
right just a little bit
right fallout 4 me and you would go i
mean you put me on you were like cog
that ain't fallout 3 they dumbed it down
a little bit with the systems you used
to be very powerful
howard came out and said yeah this is
going to be more towards their core
right so and we we kind of know what
last point we kind of know what elder
scrolls
is you know we get that fallout the next
one we know what that is
but if they could establish a new ip
for the new generation that's fire
that's critically acclaimed and now you
only get that on microsoft
man that hits different what you think
all right so let me get these two super
chats
we got a final super stream from bernard
miller shout out
laura cog and attic just a bullet for
the chamber for a sega purchase
the highest rated publisher from 2020
is sega microsoft was the fourth and p.s
was the fifth
i love how they had to put playstation
they had a football slander so we got a
two dollar super chat from carlos
sony has no road map for the remainder
of the year
i think it's actually debatable carlos
in terms of a playstation 5
exclusive scenario that uh xbox
show yeah xbox actually i think has more
next-gen
exclusive titles it's probably going to
come out in the next couple weeks we got
we got to wait for that soda show i'm
very curious to see what they actually
talk about so when it comes to the games
i feel like i feel like what you think
i got three yeah i think that starfield
is the most important in terms of
building
building up hype and i think star field
is is important for two reasons because
it's going to validate next year that
this is the reason you need an xbox
and it's going to to pretty much like
go in there and spring clean bethesda
like
because it's like once you spring clean
bethesda it's like look like
76 was a fluke like this isn't how we
roll and i i feel like once
once they show people this is our
product 76 we just helped with
sure that's still under our brand we
have to take that but this studio didn't
make that game
right this is 18 they got it they got to
establish that though because they
people yeah people would talk to talk
greasy i think the second one
ironically it's fable uh because
i think fable and it's not just like me
being it's not just because you know
fable is it's like i've been told fable
they have just as much budget behind
fables they do halo
they want fable to be the next pillar of
xbox and
i think that when it comes to that they
want rpgs to be this
front and center for for xbox and they
want
hey they want fable to be in the front
of that because
that's why they had playground making it
like playground was gonna go
they were gonna do something completely
different and the ideal of fable
is the reason that microsoft bought them
because they had an idea with one of
their brands
and the third one is elder scrolls 6.
because i think that if elder scrolls 6
is anything like skyrim
skyrim to this day oh
completely changed that genre and
imagine
if we have a similar scenario that
happens with six
maybe even on a bigger scale because
we're on new gen technology
like way newer to technology and it's an
exclusive
like people we've never had an exclusive
elder scrolls game and we're about to
imagine morrowind morrowind was at the
time
yeah yeah technically yeah yeah you
could count that because it because
it couldn't run on that x or the
playstation so i'm curious to see what
happens there
i'm curious to see who's working on
fallout
yeah because i don't think they're
working on fallout i think another
studio is working on fallout i just
don't know who
because to me i feel like but as this
software was making
fallout because they had to make
following what if you get
in exiles back in the building i'm i'm
okay with that letting something
make salad because i think they can
easily do that also
obsidian i don't think in the building i
don't want them sitting in a mcfarlane
you don't know new vegas i i i love
vegas but to me right down the hall
apartment you don't want you want to go
hit up with
me to me obsidian has fought
so hard to be on them to get their own
ips and get their own branding
that's why they announced notice outer
world 2 got announced probably two years
before it comes out
uh a vow it's probably coming out the
the in the next year at the beginning of
the year after that
they they have fought so hard to get to
this point
i don't want microsoft obviously if they
agree to it that's one thing but
i low-key want them to work on their own
branding
and you can see there's clearly a rival
would be going on between them
you know what's funny we talk about
rivalry we talk about obsidian let's be
real they signed
not knowing that bethesda would be down
without with the team
what's funny is what if a vowed
is the elder scrolls game of the year
type
killer like what if it's a vow that
would be interesting twist
if starfield comes out in november and a
vow comes out like march
of the next year because of that
that's around the time a valve would
come out like a probably could put
pressure on
but that's definitely like yo who's the
who's the king of the office
that would be crazy the outer worlds 2
coming out like 2024 the beginning of
2024
like it's like you know we've said on
the iron lures podcast multiple times
people aren't ready what's about to
happen and especially a lot of these
like crazy
you know fanboys that that live and
breathe the console more stuff on
twitter you're not prepared for the
spirit bombs
microsoft has been making for eight
years they cook
you know it could blow up in their face
man it could be one of those things
where they about to throw that spirit
bomb and he just drops it and falls on
top of it it got like i said
like like a main thing i said the games
got to be quality
the games have to hit you got the
resources you got the money
now produce and if you do what you're
supposed to do
it's all set up for them it's it's
literally set up for them to do
this thing that's a layup they gotta
they gotta complete it yeah
and you know speaking of all the games
that we talked about
all these reasons that they could really
use this franchise
by the time these bigger games are
coming out the fables the elder scrolls
sixes the
uh the star fields i honestly feel like
x-cloud will be in a position to where
you could be on the bus playing a vow
and you know and i think that the longer
time goes by
it's going to be more accessible in
terms of how you play it on your phone
because like right now it's i don't
think
i it is accessible but i think in the
next couple years
you're gonna see 5g rolling out you're
going to see better accessories to make
it easier roll out
and i think once you see this going out
that's when people are going to see
where microsoft's vision was their
vision was game pass
as the center and then xbox is a pillar
to
ex to have access to game pass
xcloud's a pillar to have access to game
pass they're doing it on your browsers
to have access to game passes
do you think that when this comes out
and xcloud is rolling out and
all these games are rolling out and then
you're able to just go on the bus
especially in other countries that don't
have the room for a console
well i honestly i want to know your
opinion uh saw
do you think that that's when game pass
doubles maybe even triples and
subscriber rates
i think i think the other the trojan
horse also i think soft talk
the browser bro i think we're sleeping
on the browser because as much as we
clown
stadia whatever that was a huge
advantage
just being able to pull up chrome
microsoft
internet explorer and you're gaming in a
browser on your laptop on your desktop
which has the stabiler connection you
know what i'm saying and you don't have
to be relying on 5g or anything yo
that's a big deal
and there's going to be markets that's
applied to the mobile we talked about
you know i'm saying
with certain markets like china and
japan or whatever
you know that's another thing i agree i
think that when you hit that mobile
market and you hit
all these different demographics and the
other thing is tvs smart tvs is a
big deal you know when you get that new
tv you got
all those apps you got your youtubes you
got your hulus you got all that
if that xbox app is right there front
and center
who's not to say oh you know what let me
see what that is i don't got a console
but let me see what that is you know
what they're going to
move they're going to work with cell
phone providers to be like look if
you're part of att
you get game pass for free and the
reason they would do something like that
is because they want it to be one of
those
tiers to where it's they they can work
out something with a t and t get a
little bit of kickback in terms of money
or
you know but they want it because when
people look at those plans
they'll be like what's this xbox game
pass xcloud thing here what is it
and then when the 18t people describe
the service to them
oh i can play games on my phone oh and
yeah
just incentivize it you just be like yo
sign up for
a t whatever whatever you get your new
phone all ready to three months
already game pass here you go the x
cloud game pass ultimate
here you go you there's no reason for
you not to try it so it's up to them to
incentivize it
as part of these deals with tvs phones
and stuff that which was what att would
probably do in like companies like that
is
if you play xcloud it doesn't go against
your data
so i i could totally see microsoft
working out scenarios like that
so we got to fight all this super chat
from the wise old gamer
shout out to wiseau gamer man i'm glad
you're feeling better and i'm glad
everything good to see you both
composure studio game will have the
largest impact if it hits you have a
former
indie studio making a critically
acclaimed triple
oh the optics and i agree with you like
because when it comes to
smaller studios they generally don't
have like
a tunnel vision site like a lot of these
bigger studios 343 coalition they've
been making the same game so long
that they have a tunnel vision of how
that game needs to be made
right uh we got a five dollar stream
from chill walker
it is uh it is flight simulator because
once it runs smooth on little man
oh yes little man won the thing little
bit i told you
yes we're going to speed
some type of emoji and put it on there
uh it won
uh attic show was second and what's
funny is i had people in the comment
section
arguing what needed to have it uh so
xbox uh little man that xbox tech that
they have been trying to develop to sign
up
will explode and i agree with you on
that i agree with you
and it's just like to me that's when
you're going to see stuff be different
you know yeah that's one you know we're
talking about
over the seas because i think that's
what xcod was made for was over the seas
to get in the asian markets
like once it casualizes in the in the
western markets
like imagine fortnight to the 10th
degree like people could just bring out
their phone
and play and play you know minecraft
play elder scrolls
six right you said you said it yourself
you know i'm i'm older you know i'm you
i guess you're considered a millennial
i'm considering what generation x
whatever right
you know you said it yourself like
zach you know your bro right your little
boy
he's doing things on his phone like he
these kids are on the
like they're not playing the games that
we we we consumed them
right it's a different generation they
play roblox on their phone they don't
even play
they don't even play on a console so
it's like at the end of the day
again that's why the play for microsoft
is smart the key is the marketing and
the access just to make sure
everyone knows what it is and that it's
accessible you could get into ecosystem
and they could definitely hit that
demographic they missed out on yeah so
you know
that's pretty much all i had today man
it's like look at the end of the day
you know what would brush up a little
bit on the playstation stuff like
i like that because it's competition i
like playstation going out there they
they're going to buy studios and
microsoft is going to buy studios
obviously microsoft's going to buy more
that's the size uh you know they're all
going to have things and you know for
people who don't think playstation is
not going to go towards the the
streaming thing you
you're you're highly mistaken they
they're making their own little
versions of it they and i'm sure there's
some people
somewhere out there making it we've got
to 10 dollar super trap smitty smith
salute to the lords and shout out to
little man
his cover is covered king probably won
it while series s with some arms on it
he wanted something he got king is good
with division so we're going to let king
come up with the concept of what little
probably
because what i don't want is i don't
want if certain
members uh you know if we if we lose
some members next month
i don't want that getting us back down
to where we can have another email
so what we'll probably do is we have a
bunch of emotes on standby
we'll put a temporarily emote there just
so we can grab it and know everybody
getting lost oh just change it
right right it's my big cloud game
what's going on bro what's going on so
you know that that's the show you know
uh i i've been doing this a little bit
uh more frequently here you know i'll be
back next
next week we should have had big cloud
in yeah how's mark
yeah definitely everyone in the chat man
big cloud actually interviewed house
mark yeah and you know what i'm
angry he didn't ask is this going to be
exclusive
so you know how dare you the audacity
big cloud that you didn't have the
foresight to go
out there and know that they were being
bought
we got a five dollar trooper chat from
big cloud gaming
uh bow to that playstation you talking
to that playstation talk
let's go i feel i see y'all out here
movie uh y'all it's coffee season y'all
y'all coughing them up yeah i'm saying
that's smart
it's is that what we're calling it
that's what we call he got a couple
mothers
before i get cold summertime
man we we we say some crazy stuff
sometimes we really do
what lord's talk you know how we do all
right so here uh
what i want you guys to do man is here
is big cloud's channel
go over there man and and he has he's
interviewed
the people over there ironically the
studios that he they just bought like
the studios they bought
white house ball and blue playing great
interviews man go over there
show them some love man uh you know
we're we will be back on iop this sunday
at 1 pm keep in mind
uh tuesday on the 6th we're going to be
streaming sea of thieves so
i'm sure some of you are going to enjoy
that and until next time this is gamie
addict and uh hey
cognito what are you doing are you gonna
announce where uh
the the thing you're doing today no i
don't know about the destiny oh bobby
okay
um yeah shout out i'm gonna be doing
it's gonna be it's not gonna be live but
uh shout out to the destiny show man
they
they've been they've been killing it and
um they're about to have pete parsons on
you know what i'm saying the ceo but you
know they asked me to do something
different they don't want to create a
series so i want to rock out with corn
and them dudes
so i will be that will probably go up at
some point but this is
just a heads up it's going to be the
point of the last weeks of my
my podcast tour called me some rest you
know saying but i had to do the attic
show the wolf of the ninja
team i was like i ain't even been on the
attic show i was like that got to change
you know what i'm saying so we got to do
that and you'll see a little bit more of
it in the future i want to definitely
pop in when i have time when things are
not as busy but salute to addicts
y'all support showing support for the
wolf and i like what he's doing so yeah
and the realm showed out today nice
salute yeah
we'll definitely